MALE SPEAKER: Hi, and
thank you for coming today.
This is a great collaboration
between the Authors Discussion
Group and the Food team.
We have Chef Margarita here,
from Chihuahua, Mexico.
Today we're talking, or she will
be discussing, various recipes
from her book,
"Mexico-- the Cookbook,"
which covers pretty much most
of the regions, or states,
in Mexico.
So without further
ado, Chef Margarita.
MARGARITA CARRILLO
ARRONTE: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Well, thank you very much.
Good afternoon.
I'm very glad to be here,
sharing with you all
this experience from
living such a long time.
And I will start
with telling you
that this is a recipe from the
Yucatan, in which the marinade
we're going to prepare can be
used in mostly any protein.
It can be used with chicken,
with fish, with shrimp,
with pork.
It will be delicious prepared
with almost anything.
We'll start with-- let me see.
We'll use the heat,
but if I take it away
from the plate, the heat, it
will not roast the banana leaf.
So I'll turn it upside down.
And you will see how
it changes color.
Look.
Are you looking?
It turns bright green-- look.
And it becomes flexible.
Look how nice.
Look.
OK, and now it's flexible.
And it doesn't break.
Otherwise, it breaks.
We are going to prepare the
marinade, which is achiote.
This achiote is annatto
seed dissolved in vinegar,
and make a paste,
together with dry roasted
garlics, fresh garlics, spices,
cinnamon, bay leaves, peppers,
allspice berries.
And we'll make it liquid
with orange juice.
If we don't have sour orange
juice, as we use in Mexico,
then you add the orange juice,
normal-- regular any orange
juice-- and vinegar.
OK, so this is ready.
We'll add epazote.
Sorry.
OK.
And we'll prepare
this with the fish,
and we'll put it in
the refrigerator.
And now we will
prepare the escabeche.
OK, we need olive oil.
The garlics-- they
have to be complete
so people can see them
and take them off,
if they don't want them.
We'll add the cinnamon bark,
some peppers, some cloves,
and some bay leaves.
[SIZZLING]
All these herbs
start protesting.
And red onion.
Very slightly.
We don't want them to get brown.
We'll add the
vinegar, the chiles.
But we have to-- in order
to have the flavor, but not
the heat, you have to make
little holes in the habanero.
Mmm.
And we'll add a
little bit of water.
OK.
Little bit of salt.
And that's it.
We have to leave this resting.
OK, this is ready.
Mmm, smells delicious.
We leave this resting.
So it will get a red color.
If you want it more
red, you put the skin--
you know, this paper-like skin
that the red onions have-- put
them in a cheese cloth,
together with a slice of beet,
tie it, and put it there,
so it will get bright red.
Sometimes you are in a hurry,
so you don't have time to.
OK, this is ready.
Now we'll prepare the fish.
Yeah, [SPANISH]?
Is that all?
OK.
We'll have the fish, a
little bit of pepper.
We use a lot of the
allspice berries,
and it's the only spice
that is from Mexican origin.
The rest is from a
lot of other places.
And the American ambassador
we had at that time,
when he discovered
it, he tasted it,
named it allspice, because
in its little berry
it has the flavor of the
black pepper, the nutmeg,
the cinnamon, and the clove.
That's why it's called allspice.
So we have onion, tomato.
[INAUDIBLE] And we will
add a little more salt/
Little bit of habanero.
If you don't want habanero,
just omit it, or put one whole,
without opening it, so
it will give the flavor,
and it will not give the heat.
OK?
That's it.
We can send it to be baked.
And this, if you don't
have an oven, no excuse.
You put it on a comal.
You don't have a
comal, a saute pan.
Put it on a saute pan,
like this, put a few drops,
like an ounce of
water on the bottom
so it creates the first
steam, and then cover it.
It will be ready in 15
minutes, 10 minutes.
That's it.
We have it finished,
so that-- OK, OK.
Questions?
Be ready with your question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MARGARITA CARRILLO
ARRONTE: Oh, yes.
I do.
No, no.
In Mexico.
Come to Mexico.
I would love to be in LA,
because my son is here, but no.
He works for the movie industry.
But no, no, no.
In Mexico.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MARGARITA CARRILLO ARRONTE: I
would be a liar if I told you.
But I'm going to
tell you something.
If they give you something with
yellow cheese, don't eat it.
We don't even have it in Mexico.
We call it American cheese.
So they have to be honest.
They have to give you-- they
know that you like fried food,
so that's why they-- and
of course, taquitos and all
these things fried
are delicious,
but it's not the only thing.
You know, I normally never,
never fry the food I eat.
But I try it in my menu.
I have nothing fried but the
totopos that I-- we fry it
every day, and
then after frying,
I put them in the oven
with lots of kitchen paper
so they let all the oil off.
Because it has a very bad
fame of being unhealthy food.
And it isn't.
It's not fair.
And there is a reason
why I understand.
At the beginning, I was very
angry with Mexican people who
cross the border,
and for me, it's
a way of prostituting the food.
They do prostitute the food.
But I understood that they come
here searching for a better way
to live, because in Mexico
they cannot find it.
We are too many.
And they come here,
they work hard,
and they open these
little places,
and they want to
be accepted madly.
They need to be accepted.
So they are willing to
adapt their traditional food
to the American taste.
So that's why they
do it, because it's
the easier-- they didn't
come here to educate you.
They came here to be accepted,
and to work hard, and to have
a better life.
So that's why they are willing
to prostitute the food,
but I don't.
So that's why I wrote this
book, and in many-- there
are a few fried
recipes, like bunuelos,
and other things, some desserts.
But mainly,
everything-- you know,
the traditional
cooking techniques
of Mexican authentic food
is on the comal, steamed,
boiled, in the pit,
through a hole in the oven,
on hot stones.
There are many other-- grilled--
many other ways, but not fried.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MARGARITA CARRILLO ARRONTE:
Well, to begin with,
they don't find the
same ingredients.
It's the most important reason.
And something else.
This is-- and you
will understand this.
You're young, intelligent guys.
You will understand that
when the Spaniards came,
they brought the pigs with them.
They brought the lard, and
they brought the olive oil,
and the frying technique.
And it was expensive.
Mexicans couldn't afford it.
Only rich people
could afford it.
So it became a way of
status, a sign of status.
Only rich people could
eat with these elements.
There is even a saying in
Mexico, from colonial times,
that when you haven't seen a
friend for a long time-- oh,
have you seen Chochito Perez?
Oh, no.
But you know, they
even cook with lard?
They are doing so well that
they even cook with lard.
So it became like they
are so wealthy now,
why, they can cook with lard.
And that has happened here, too.
When they come here,
they have a better life,
and they can cook with oil.
So the most remembered
things-- you know,
food is completely
mingled-- Mexican food
is completely mingled with the
culture, with the religion,
and especially is
with the feelings.
When you are sick,
you immediately
remember what your mother cooked
for you when you were young.
You were little.
You remember it well.
So food, as it becomes
something mixed
with the feelings, and
the homesickness, and all
these things-- they want
the most popular street food
that reminds them of the food
from Chiapas, or from wherever
they are.
So they cook.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MARGARITA CARRILLO
ARRONTE: Achiote?
Annatto.
It's a bush that gives
a bright, red flower.
But in the heart of it has
like a pod, like an open pod.
And you open this
pod, and inside it's
like a corn kernel,
a little corn kernel.
And instead of white kernels,
it has red bright kernels.
And it's the annatto seeds.
And everybody
there, what they do
is put them in a jar with
vinegar or sour orange juice,
and let them soak.
But they are going to use them.
They mix them with dry roasted
garlic, cinnamon, black pepper,
with spices.
And they have their achiote.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MARGARITA CARRILLO ARRONTE:
You can buy it here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MARGARITA CARRILLO ARRONTE:
Yes, the color is--
and the food looks
delicious, and the flavor.
And you can buy it in all
Mexican or South American
stores.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MARGARITA CARRILLO
ARRONTE: Of course.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MARGARITA CARRILLO ARRONTE: OK.
A lot of-- I could tell you
that the most important thing
is the practice.
So don't be disappointed
and not try again.
Try again.
Your dog will be very happy
eating horrible tortillas,
but well cooked.
And just mix the masa
harina with-- if you're
making like a kilo
of masa harina,
just have a bolito
like that, of my size,
not yours-- you know, like this.
50 grams of wheat flour.
Mix it there, and add warm
water, tepid water that you
can put your little
finger, and count until 10,
without burning yourself.
Don't go, one, two,
three, four, five, aah!
No.
Just warm water.
And mix it.
Enough water.
And it has to be a little
bit sticky at the end,
but then it's perfect.
And you just make the little
bolitas, put them in the press.
And the flat pan, the comal,
has to be thick and very hot,
hot enough to seal the
tortilla right away.
But as you don't
have any practice,
and you will burn
your fingers if you
try to turn the tortilla,
have one of those spatulas,
and turn it.
And that's it.
Why didn't they work out well?
They broke?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MARGARITA CARRILLO
ARRONTE: Practice.
Yes, and the dough
has to be wet.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MARGARITA CARRILLO
ARRONTE: Masa.
It has to be corn, but not from
Colombia or-- because that's
not made from nixtamal.
It has to be masa harina
from Mexico, Maseca
or-- what's the other name?
Maseca or-- I don't remember
the name of the other.
But it has to be corn,
nixtamalized flour, corn flour.
That's the secret.
If it's too white, then
it's not the good one.
It's light sand color.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MARGARITA CARRILLO
ARRONTE: Buy a Mexican one.
And don't hesitate
to add enough water.
And if it's too wet,
add a little bit more,
and no problem.
It's not like flour
harina that you
will develop the
gluten, and all this.
No, this hasn't
got that problem.
And it's very, very delicious.
Don't add any salt to it.
OK?
Well, something else.
It's important.
Here-- I didn't make
enough marinade,
but normally you have a
lot of marinade left over.
What you do is you boil it,
reduce it, and then add it
to the fish, or to the
chicken, or whatever.
And what you have to do is serve
with-- where's the escabeche?
You put it on top,
OK, on top, on top.
And a little bit more
olive oil, and you serve it
with fried plantain.
And the plantain,
where are they?
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
MARGARITA CARRILLO
ARRONTE: Yes, over there.
The blackened, the better.
You will never eat a--
this plantain is not ready.
Touch it.
It's very hard.
It has to be black, more black,
much more black than that.
OK, if you-- beans.
Beans.
In the southeast of Mexico,
and the south in general,
we always eat black beans.
In the north, we
always eat brown beans.
Yes, yes.
A little bit of olive oil.
You have to help
yourselves from here.
And you can have
your achiote ready.
Once you dirty your
blender, you buy
a big piece of achiote
paste, and roast garlic,
and fresh garlic, and
dry roasted cinnamon,
and pepper, and oregano--
everything blended
with vinegar.
And you make a paste,
like a lighter paste.
Put it in your fridge, and
you keep it there for months.
That's it.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MARGARITA CARRILLO
ARRONTE: Mainly.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MARGARITA CARRILLO
ARRONTE: Oh, yes.
We ate a lot of fish.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MARGARITA CARRILLO
ARRONTE: Well, it
was before the Spaniards came.
It was in the 1900s--
no, the 1500s.
But then they came, and they
brought all the animals.
So they mixed.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MARGARITA CARRILLO
ARRONTE: I'm not-- well,
we have a different
system of eating.
What we do, we have a
very good breakfast--
not coffee and doughnuts.
We have eggs, beans,
a heavy breakfast.
And then just a lunch--
you know, chicken.
Kids take to school a
sandwich, or something.
Then we have a very heavy meal
at lunch time, 3:00-- 2:00
or 3:00 in the afternoon-- but
heavy soup, vegetables, fish,
whatever, dessert,
and everything.
And then in the
evening, a light dinner.
We have like a quesadilla, or
a bowl of cereal, or a yogurt,
or something light
in the evening.
It's a different system.
But the most important
meal is-- yes,
and we have fish, and a
lot of vegetables, yes.
But please, it's getting cold.
So I don't know, what's
the mechanic here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MARGARITA CARRILLO ARRONTE:
OK, there are plates.
And please help yourselves.
Otherwise it's going to be--
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
MARGARITA CARRILLO
ARRONTE: Thank you.